you know honestly I swear to God that
Jason and I didn't coordinate our
outfits tonight this was this is purely
accidental but you know it just goes to
show doesn't it that these days a
Hawaiian God and a very mature English
woman can actually wear the same color
we can both wear pink finally time to
change documentary filmmakers bring us
stories of real people doing real things
and doing so they can often open our
eyes to the most important issues of
yesterday today and tomorrow
they are insightful they're illuminating
sometimes astonishing always authentic
and revelatory here are the nominees for
Best Documentary Feature free solo
Elizabeth chivor Cirelli Jimmy Chang
Evan Hayes and shallow Jill Hale County
this morning this evening Rimmel Ross
Justin Barnes and sue Kim minding the
gap Bing Liu and Diane corn our fathers
and sons
Talal Turkey
and scoff freely Efik MA and Tobias NZ
but our BG Betsy Western Julie :
and the Oscar goes to free so though
[Applause]
this is the first Oscar nomination for
Elizabeth chive Vasarely Jimmy chin
kevin hayes and shannon dill
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
thank you thank you um
[Music]
Thank You National Geographic for
believing in US and for hiring women and
people of color if you only help make
the films better thank you to all the
amazing people who worked on this film
evan Shannon our high-angle team I mean
it was it was a work of an army and we
appreciate you in every way thank you to
our families especially our two kids
Marina I know you're here James
and then thank you to Sandy McCandless
you climbed your own mountain that day
so thank you sunny this film would be so
boring without you I'm just saying okay
okay anyway thank you Alex Honnold
for giving us courage at teaching us how
to believe in the impossible and
inspiring us this film is for everyone
who believes in the impossible thank you